[Music]
thumbs up soda it's very suspicious
bottle like I could seen some [ __ ] looks
like coca-cola thumbs up oh it tastes
like Indian Pepsi that was like carpet
but I wanted to convert sip and it
tastes like Coke I actually kind of
liked it more um without the be th UMS I
mean I guess in their defense that's how
thumbs like should be spelled aloo
masala what why wow I just experienced
18 different sensations it's like oh
this tastes like nothing I've ever had
before
oh it really tastes like nothing I've
ever had before it's served pretty spicy
I don't know what I want more and you're
like spicy food man I like it just super
good
go jeah I feel like there's a utensil
you're not giving me this is like
impossible to eat are there instructions
there's no instruction it's actually
quite fragrant this is spicy -
challenges your palate kicks you in the
face oh good
the number the first ingredient is lost
flour what that look is moth flour love
it's kind of awesome but I can't handle
it hodge mala drugs medicine it kind of
looks like baby food oh yeah I thought
this was like a little like danimals
yogurt
Oh oh wow are you sure this is for
eating I'm not doing it it says to take
two of them and chew em what is this oh
yeah I'm done with this
these taste like the chemical farts uh
there's like a spice vitamin yeah try it
pani puri yeah oh these are fun
it looks like it's fun to eat what
there's nothing inside mmm delicious
delicious I'm so relieved
eat this after all I've been through
this looks like a bunch of seashells
hanging out on the beach who knows what
that means but it looks like it's fun to
eat